Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Après des épisodes plutôt intenses avec Hugues Dayez, Julie Dachez ou encore Frédéric Chardon, cette semaine, un épisode un peu plus light.
Je suis allé au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles et j'ai rencontré Barbara Trachte, qui est chef de groupe Écolo.
On a parlé d'enseignement puisque c'est sa spécialité et cet épisode s'inscrit donc un petit peu dans la continuité des discussions que j'avais pu avoir avec Nicolas Reland, Charlotte Bellière ou encore Jérôme Colin.
Enfin, on parle aussi des élections fédérales qui ont eu lieu récemment. Autrement dit, si vous nous écoutez depuis l'étranger, c'est un épisode qui est peut-être très belgo-belge dans sa thématique, mais rassurez-vous,
les prochains épisodes devraient compenser.
Let's go ! Nous sommes aujourd'hui au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles avec madame Barbara Trachte. Barbara Trachte, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes chef de groupe Écolo au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles. Vous suivez particulièrement les dossiers liés à l'enseignement, aux droits des enfants et à la place des enfants dans les villes.
Mmm-hmm.
Première question : on vous sent particulièrement attachée aux questions liées à l'enseignement. Comment ça se fait ?
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez ça ?
C'est à la fois une combinaison entre, ben, mon histoire, hein, mon passé et puis, j'ai envie de dire, des coïncidences ou des aléas.
Mon passé parce que, en fait, j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la politique dans les années 90. Y a eu des grandes grèves dans l'enseignement alors que j'étais moi-même élève à l'école secondaire.
Et donc la question qui m'a amenée à m'intéresser à la politique, c'est vraiment la question des politiques d'enseignement et de l'impact
des mesures d'austérité qui étaient adoptées à l'époque, hein, dans les années 90, et qui avaient un impact sur les écoles.
C'est la première question politique qui m'a intéressée, j'ai envie de dire, personnellement, spontanément. Avant ça, je vivais dans une famille que la politique intéressait
globalement, mais c'était, disons, plus à l'initiative de mes parents qu'à mon initiative personnelle.
Donc vraiment, la première question politique qui m'a intéressée personnellement, c'était la question des politiques d'enseignement.
Ensuite, ben, suite à ces grèves, au retour dans les écoles, malheureusement, à la suite de ces grèves, j'ai voulu comprendre comment le monde politique fonctionnait.
C'est comme ça que j'ai commencé des études de droit.
Je suis devenue ensuite avocate et j'ai travaillé de nouveau sur les questions d'enseignement, puisque je travaillais dans un cabinet qui défendait notamment la Communauté française.
Et puis, je suis devenue députée et à ce moment-là, une place s'est libérée ici, au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, au sein de mon groupe, hein, puisque tous les députés bruxellois
ne sont pas députés à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles. On est 19 sur les 72 à être quelque part délégués, les délégués bruxellois au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Et y avait une place disponible au sein du groupe Écolo. Et quand je suis arrivée ici, y avait une place disponible au sein de la commission enseignement.
Donc voilà, c'est à la fois
Mmm-hmm
...mon histoire et, voilà, des hasards, des coïncidences.
D'une part, un intérêt personnel et d'autre part, le fait que-
Mmm-hmm
...la place était dispo.
Voilà.
C'est ça. OK. Et donc, est-ce qu'il y a, je dirais, dans votre parcours d'élève bruxelloise ici en secondaire à Schaerbeek,
une frustration dans la façon dont vous avez connu l'enseignement ici ?
Ou est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose que vous souhaitiez réformer, changer, voire évoluer ? Ou bien est-ce que vous étiez finalement assez contente de votre parcours en tant qu'élève ?
Moi, j'ai-
Dans les invités que j'ai eus dans ce podcast, y a ceux qui adoraient l'école-
Oui
...et y a ceux qui la détestent brutalement. On n'est généralement pas trop neutre. Soit on aime bien, soit on déteste.
Vous étiez laquelle, vous ?
Moi, j'ai adoré. J'ai adoré l'école. Et je trouve que, enfin, je souhaiterais que tous les enfants et tous les adolescents puissent bénéficier de la scolarité dont moi, j'ai bénéficié.
Pas le même parcours, mais la même bienveillance et le même intérêt et surtout le plaisir d'apprendre qui m'a été inculqué très tôt.
Donc j'ai eu la chance d'être en primaire dans une école à pédagogie active, où très tôt, j'ai appris l'autonomie, et le plaisir d'apprendre, très tôt.
L'école à pédagogie active ?
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que c'est exactement ?
Ben, les pédagogies actives, y a plusieurs écoles, hein, enfin, oui, plusieurs écoles, mais donc plusieurs courants.
Y a notamment Freinet, Montessori, qui est aujourd'hui de plus en plus à la mode.
Donc c'était alors dans l'enseignement privé ?
Non, non, c'était dans l'enseignement libre subventionné. Donc, euh-
C'est ça
...c'est une école catholique.
D'accord, ouais.
Mais y a des écoles officielles qui pratiquent les pédagogies actives depuis fort longtemps, hein, y compris ici à Bruxelles, à Clairvivre, notamment, à Evere.
C'est une école communale à pédagogie active,
depuis très très longtemps.
Mais donc l'idée des pédagogies actives, c'est d'apprendre
assez vite aux enfants l'autonomie et de laisser assez vite les enfants apprendre par eux-mêmes, hein, de leur donner les différentes possibilités, les différents outils qui sont disponibles dans la classe pour apprendre,
de pratiquer aussi beaucoup les
les interactions entre pairs.
Mais alors, entre pairs, c'est pas nécessairement les enfants du même âge, c'est aussi être mélangé avec des enfants plus jeunes ou plus âgés, et des enfants qui vont enseigner et apprendre en même temps.
Donc les plus âgés vont apprendre aux plus jeunes, ceux qui sont plus avancés vont apprendre à ceux qui sont moins avancés.
C'est vraiment une méthode d'enseignement qui est moins frontale. C'est moins l'enseignant qui déverse son savoir à tous les élèves en même temps.
C'est beaucoup plus les élèves qui sont occupés à des ateliers, qui s'occupent par eux-mêmes et qui sont eux-mêmes responsables de leur évolution.
Donc ça, c'est très-
Donc ça, c'est pour la définition. Et donc, vous, vous êtes très, très contente, très, très satisfaite de votre parcours en pédagogie active.
Oui.
Et vous dites, vous aimeriez que tout le monde puisse connaître un parcours similaire ?
Oui. Ben oui, parce que-
Donc c'est l'exemple à suivre, finalement, pour le reste des courants ?
Je ne pense pas que ce soit nécessairement généralisable parce qu'il y a des contre-exemples. Je veux dire, dans ma famille même, je connais des enfants auxquels ça a moins bien réussi.
Ça a très bien réussi avec moi et ça a très bien réussi avec plein d'enfants. Et je pense que ça a un potentiel d'épanouissement très très grand.
Et j'aimerais bien que beaucoup plus d'enfants puissent en bénéficier. Je ne sais pas s'il faut nécessairement généraliser ça à tout le monde parce que, en fait, je pense qu'il y a
il y a pas de pédagogie type qui va fonctionner avec tout le monde, hein, que ce soit des pédagogies plus traditionnelles
ou les pédagogies actives ou même les méthodes de lecture dont on parle régulièrement.
Je pense pas qu'il y a une méthode qui soit la bonne pour tout le monde. Mais en tout cas, dans les pédagogies actives, il y a vraiment, je trouve, par rapport à l'évolution de la société et par rapport au plaisir d'apprendre, vraiment des
des enseignements à en tirer pour tout le monde.
De la rajouter, ouais.
Et je trouve que, voilà, surtout dans le monde dans lequel on vit, où les savoirs évoluent très fort et se multiplient de plus en plus, tout savoir, ce sera impossible.
Par contre, avoir le plaisir d'apprendre, la curiosité, et savoir quelque part se débrouiller, je pense que c'est vraiment des capacités essentielles.
Et donc actuellement, ces écoles-là sont très minoritaires dans le parc des, oui, dans les réseaux d'enseignement ici en Belgique, c'est très minoritaire finalement.
Donc, vous aimeriez voir une expansion-
Oui
...de la pédagogie active ?
Oui, oui. C'est minoritaire, mais ça l'est de moins en moins. Je--
de plus en plus, ben, notamment en raison de l'essor démographique ici à Bruxelles, il y a de plus en plus d'écoles qui se créent et de plus en plus d'écoles à pédagogie active.
Et il y a de nombreuses écoles aussi qui se convertissent, si j'ose dire, hein-
D'accord
...qui se transforment, dans des réseaux-
Vous avez des exemples ?
Oui oui oui, il y en a, il y en a, ben donc des écoles qui se créent.
Ben je pense, par exemple, pour parler de Schaerbeek que je connais bien, il y a une nouvelle école qui s'appelle l'École Neuve, qui va ouvrir là en septembre, une école communale qui sera à pédagogie active.
Mais il y a une autre école qui est l'école seize, qui est aussi une école communale, qui était une école à pédagogie plus traditionnelle, qui devient une école à pédagogie active.
Mmh.
Et puis, il y a de plus en plus d'enseignants qui, sans être nécessairement dans une école entièrement à pédagogie active, pratiquent des pédagogies actives dans leur classe.
Il y a d'autres écoles, pour citer d'autres réseaux, par exemple, l'école du Tivoli à Laeken, qui est une école de la Ville de Bruxelles, est aussi une école qui a évolué vers-
Mmh
...vers les pédagogies actives.
Ces exemples-là, ces exemples d'écoles autrefois plus traditionnelles qui deviennent aujourd'hui des écoles à pédagogie active, je trouve ça très intéressant puisque moi, j'ai justement ce cliché en tête de
de l'enseignement très conservateur, très inerte, où on...
Voilà, j'étais en interview avec Alexander De Croo il y a un an et il parlait de l'école en disant : « Ben, est-ce que l'école a évolué par rapport à il y a trente ans ?
Finalement, assez peu. »
Oui.
Donc là, vous me donnez des exemples d'écoles où on se dit : « Ben non, on jette tout par la fenêtre-
Oui
...ou presque, et on repart sur un nouveau modèle. »
Oui oui. Donc c'est tout à fait porteur d'espoir. Je trouve globalement que notre enseignement fonctionne même plus qu'il y a trente ans.
J'ai envie de dire qu'il y a plus de-- La société a fort évolué, les familles ont fort évolué, le rapport à la connaissance, surtout avec l'apparition du numérique, est en train d'évoluer très très fort et l'école évolue très peu.
Mais en effet, il y a certaines écoles, et de plus en plus, et je m'en réjouis, et dans tous les réseaux, donc c'est plus le cliché des écoles à pédagogie active qui sont uniquement des écoles privées ou des écoles,
des écoles de la Félicie, hein, donc des écoles libres.
Non, il y a aussi des écoles de l'enseignement officiel qui se tournent vers les pédagogies actives et je trouve que c'est vraiment positif.
Et en tout cas, c'est quelque chose que nous, on essaye à chaque fois, les écologistes, hein, dans les communes, de pousser le plus possible.
Ou de soutenir d'une manière ou d'une autre quand ce sont des écoles libres, d'essayer de leur faciliter la vie pour qu'elles puissent s'ouvrir.
Mmh. Yes. Sur le plan de l'enseignement, la Belgique se caractérise, se différencie de nos voisins par, voilà, son approche très décentralisée.
Mmh-mmh.
On fonctionne sur trois réseaux, trois communautés. Et, en conséquence, il y a plus de la moitié des élèves francophones qui vont dans l'enseignement catholique.
Vous aviez introduit, il y a-- c'était en 2015, il me semble, donc il y a déjà quatre ans déjà, un décret au sein du Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles pour examiner la haute proportion d'exemples sexistes dans-
Oui
...les manuels scolaires.
Oui.
Où est-ce que ça en est aujourd'hui ?
Alors, c'est aussi très, très-- 'Fin, c'est une réponse qui est un peu triste pour moi d'apporter. C'est que ce décret qu'on avait déposé avec ma collègue Hélène Ryckmans, il a été voté.
Donc l'idée, c'était de dire que, avant de recevoir un agrément, parce que les manuels scolaires, en fait, les enseignants peuvent utiliser les manuels qu'ils souhaitent.
On est dans un modèle très libéral par rapport à cela. Mais certains manuels reçoivent un agrément, c'est-à-dire que la Communauté française y appose un cachet.
Et quand il y a ce cachet, ben non seulement il atteste du fait que ce manuel répond au socle de compétences et à ce qui est attendu
des élèves à un certain niveau, donc il correspond à ce qu'on attend dans les écoles à certaines années.
Mais en outre, ça permet aux écoles d'obtenir des financements complémentaires pour acquérir ces manuels-là.
Donc, les manuels scolaires qui sont agréés, ben ils reviennent moins chers à l'achat pour les écoles et pour les enseignants.
Et donc nous, on avait dit qu'au moment d'examiner, de mettre en œuvre cette procédure d'agrément, on avait ajouté un critère qui était celui de
de vérifier qu'il n'y avait pas de stéréotypes sexistes véhiculés par les manuels.
C'est très important parce que des études, il y en a de nombreuses, ont démontré que dans les manuels scolaires, y compris les manuels scolaires agréés, il y a des stéréotypes sexistes énormes.
Je veux dire, n'importe qui peut ouvrir le manuel et s'en rendre compte. Je veux dire, les exemples qui sont donnés dans les études, c'est à pleurer quoi.
On voit le papa qui nettoie la voiture pendant que maman fait la cuisine quoi c'est-- et on demande de conjuguer ou de, 'fin voilà, à partir d'exemples comme ceux-là.
On imagine bien. Et puis des exemples de personnages historiques, des exemples de célébrités-
Oui
...très majoritairement des hommes.
Oui, là, c'est même un peu, mais je veux dire, basiquement, les exemples sont assez terrifiants. Donc il y avait un travail à faire évident.
Et donc on a réussi à faire adopter ce décret. On était très contents. Et il y a un mois et demi, deux mois, donc au moins, en mars, la ministre a déposé sur la table un décret qui supprime cette procédure d'agrément.
La procédure d'agrément n'existera plus. Et ben le critère qu'on avait ajouté a disparu avec l'eau du bain, si j'ose dire.
Tout ça, voilà.
On nous assure que, bien sûr, les éditeurs vont faire attention, mais bon, pendant cinquante ans, ils ont fait attention et les études ont démontré que ça ne suffisait pas.
Donc moi, j'espère que la législature qui vient, là, celle qui commence, on va pouvoir quand même mettre en place un filtre comme celui-là parce que c'est indispensable.
Oui. Mais donc cette approche libérale dont vous parlez, elle est assez emblématique de la façon dont l'enseignement est organisé ici en Belgique.
Est-ce que vous êtes satisfaite de cette approche où finalement, on laisse les écoles décider quel livre ils utilisent ?
On laisse les éditeurs décider ce qu'ils choisissent de publier ou non et s'ils veulent l'approbation de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles ou non ?
Ou bien est-ce que vous êtes plutôt de ceux ou de celles qui désirent une approche plus ferme où on contrôle un peu, on prend un peu plus les choses en main ?
Est-ce que vous êtes satisfaite de l'approche actuelle ?
Moi, je ne suis ni pour un État super centralisateur qui contrôle tout et qui dirige tout, ni pour une société complètement dérégulée.
Mh.
Et donc je vois bien que en matière d'enseignement, je l'observe, les écoles qui fonctionnent bien,
celles qui permettent à, notamment à des enfants défavorisés ou qui ont plus de difficultés par rapport aux apprentissages à évoluer, ce sont des écoles qui se sont mises en projet et qui ont choisi leur projet.
Pas des projets qui leur sont imposés, ce sont des projets d'équipes pédagogiques qui ont décidé entre elles de réfléchir, de faire
des constats par rapport à leur manière de travailler, au public qu'elles accueillent et de mettre en œuvre des pédagogies ou des méthodes qui correspondent à ce public et qui correspondent aussi à leurs aspirations.
C'est comme ça que ça marche. Les écoles qui fonctionnent bien, c'est comme ça que ça marche. Donc c'est difficile d'imposer la même chose à tout le monde quand on fait ce constat-là.
Ceci dit, on ne peut pas non plus, je veux dire, on ne peut pas non plus tout laisser,
tout laisser faire et sans intervenir, parce qu'on voit bien que un des gros problèmes de notre système scolaire, c'est les inégalités.
Et ça, on peut pas, c'est inacceptable, je veux dire, sociétalement. D'ailleurs, c'est la Communauté française qui finance.
C'est normal qu'elle régule. Mais donc moi, je trouvais que la procédure d'agrément des manuels scolaires, elle était pas mauvaise.
C'est, on est dans un système libéral, oui, les enseignants peuvent choisir les méthodes et les manuels qu'ils souhaitent,
mais on leur dit que ces manuels-là, ben ils correspondent un peu mieux quand même au socle de compétences qui sont attendues de toutes les écoles.
Parce que c'est quand même normal que la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles dise : à tel niveau, à telle année, il faut avoir atteint tel niveau.
Ça, c'est quand même-
Mais les établissements restent libres de dire : moi, je m'en fous, je veux mon livre sexiste.
Oui. Ben, donc, il y a, bon, il y a la question des moyens qui était liée à ça, qui est une question cruciale pour les écoles.
Donc, je veux dire, le fait d'obtenir des moyens pour des manuels scolaires agréés, c'est en soi déjà une bonne manière de les inciter à prendre ceux-là et pas d'autres.
Donc moi, je trouvais-- Et par ailleurs, bon la liberté, le revers de la médaille, c'est aussi que quand on se retrouve
dans une société complètement dérégulée ou avec un marché du livre scolaire qui est tellement large comme celui qu'on connaît aujourd'hui,
on a parfois aussi d'autres choses à faire que d'aller examiner chaque manuel scolaire et voir lequel correspond le mieux.
Alors je trouvais que le système d'agrément, ça permettait une forme de régulation,
liée notamment à la question du financement, puisque seuls les manuels agréés étaient financés, et en même temps une forme de liberté.
Je trouvais que c'était un bon équilibre.
Oui, et donc ce caractère, oui, cet héritage, disons, sexiste de ces manuels scolaires-
Mh
...est-ce que vous le mettez en lien avec le caractère religieux de la majorité des écoles ici en Belgique ou est-ce que...
Non, pas spécialement. Je veux dire, je le mets en lien avec la société, globalement. Une société qui a été façonnée par des années d'histoire dans laquelle la religion avait une place importante.
Donc, je veux dire, en soi, mais-
Ça en fait partie.
Oui, mais en soi, il n'y a pas plus de sexisme dans les manuels scolaires, dans les écoles catholiques que dans les manuels scolaires, dans les...
Voilà. C'est une so-- Et globalement, il y a du sexisme dans l'ensemble de la société, qu'elle soit laïque ou catholique.
Je veux dire, il y a un problème qui concerne tout le monde.
Suite à la vague verte qu'on a connue il y a quelques semaines, Écolo est en bonne position pour sortir de l'opposition à Bruxelles, en Wallonie et à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Comment se passent les négociations à ce stade ? Quelle majorité est-ce que vous espérez voir se dégager au sein de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles ?
Donc aujourd'hui, on est à une semaine des élections. À ce stade, c'est assez calme hein, donc le roi a désigné des informateurs.
Et par ailleurs, au niveau des régions, le Parti socialiste, qui est le premier parti, qui a donc la main, consulte les différents partis.
Donc, à ce stade, on n'est pas en négociation. À ce stade, voilà, on est reçu par les uns et les autres. Mais effectivement, notre souhait, quand on fait de la politique, c'est de changer la société.
Mais vos espoirs, vos analyses, vos-- vous vous attendez à faire partie de la majorité ?
Moi, j'espère. Je dis c'est, je veux dire c'est à ça qu'on travaille. C'est à ça qu'on a travaillé pendant cinq ans quand on était dans l'opposition.
Le but, c'est de changer la société. C'est pour ça qu'on fait de la politique. Et on la change mieux quand on est dans un gouvernement que quand on est en dehors.
Moi, je serais vraiment très triste que le résultat de cette élection, surtout quand,
quand on les a gagnées, et puis quand on a vécu aussi cinq années dans l'opposition, un peu difficile, j'espère qu'on va aller en majorité.
Et dans ce cas-là, le poste de la m-- du ministère de l'Enseignement,
pose question. Est-ce que vous êtes candidate au poste de ministre de l'Enseignement ou est-ce que vous êtes parfaitement OK avec l'idée que madame Marie-Martine Schyns reprenne son rôle ?
À ce stade, ce que j'espère, c'est qu'on sera en majorité et je vais,
je vais me donner à fond pour qu'on puisse être en majorité et négocier un bon accord,
y compris en matière d'enseignement, où il y a beaucoup de choses à faire, beaucoup de choses à faire aussi avec les acteurs de l'enseignement d'ailleurs, hein,
qui ont travaillé la législature passée.
À titre personnel, j'ai pas aujourd'hui d'autres ambitions que celles-là. On verra bien dans-
D'accord. Donc pas d'ambition ministérielle ou autre.
Ben on verra, on verra à la fin des négociations. Moi, je souhaite qu'on négocie. Je vais vraiment me donner à fond pour qu'on ait de bonnes négociations, et puis qu'on puisse obtenir des-
Oui, j'ai bien compris que les choses étaient encore très floues à ce stade. Mais dans ce cas-là, au sujet de la dernière administration, la dernière législature,
quel regard est-ce que vous portez sur ce pacte pour un enseignement d'excellence qui a été soit,
'fin, qui a été souvent très critiqué, j'dirais rarement bien compris.
Je pense que souvent, on l'a critiqué sans l'avoir lu. Quel regard est-ce que vous portez sur ce pacte ?
Moi, je pense que c'est indispensable de faire une grande réforme de l'enseignement.
Je pense que tout le monde politique est d'accord pour dire ça.
Oui, mais même, c'était pas, en 2014, c'était juste avant les élections, il y a juste, 'fin, il y a un peu plus que cinq ans maintenant, des acteurs de la société civile nous l'avaient demandé, hein.
La plateforme de lutte contre l'échec scolaire, qui rassemble des parents, des chercheurs, des associations, nous avait dit : « Écoutez, ça peut plus continuer comme ça.
Il y a trop d'inégalités et il y a pas assez de plaisir d'enseigner et de plaisir d'apprendre. » Et donc il faut une grande réforme de l'enseignement.
Ils nous avaient demandé une grande réforme qui passe au-delà, qui perdure au-delà des législatures, parce qu'on réforme pas l'enseignement en cinq ans.
Il faut plus que cinq ans. C'est ça que la majorité qui s'est mise en place après 2014 a entamé sous l'égide de ce qu'ils ont appelé le Pacte d'excellence.
Alors nous, on l'aurait pas appelé comme ça. Je trouve que c'est pas le-
C'est très américain comme nom hein.
Et puis, je trouve que par rapport à l'ambition de donner le plaisir d'apprendre et même de lutter contre les inégalités, c'est pas le terme idéal.
Nous, on aurait préféré qu'on parle d'émancipation, par exemple, ou de plaisir d'apprendre. Oui, je trouve l'idée de plaisir d'apprendre et le fait qu'on donne aux enfants,
cette curiosité, cette envie est plus intéressante que l'excellence où on parle-- 'fin quand on entend excellence, on parle de-
Résultat ouais
...on entend compétition, on entend résultats mesurables. 'Fin, je trouve que c'est pas-- voilà. Mais bon, voilà, c'est le terme qu'ils ont choisi.
Ils ont aussi choisi une méthode qui n'aurait pas-- nous, on aurait choisi une autre méthode.
Je trouve qu'il y a quand même une difficulté avec les enseignants, les enseignants qui-- les enseignants chacun dans leur classe, en fait, hein.
Ce processus, même s'il est moins top down qu'avant, puisque des représentants des réseaux, des syndicats, des associations de parents, etc., ont été impliqués,
ça reste quand même un processus qui s'est passé à huis clos, avec des personnes qui sont des délégués, et qui sont quelque part assez loin des personnes qu'elles représentent. Et donc, le,
dans chaque classe, il y a effectivement beaucoup d'enseignants qui ne comprennent pas très bien et ce qu'il y a dans le pacte d'excellence et en quoi ça peut améliorer,
leur quotidien, leur manière d'enseigner et finalement, le futur de leurs élèves.
Donc il y a eu un problème, me semble-t-il, en termes d'appropriation et de participation des enseignants au processus.
Et enfin, il fallait aussi, je pense, c'était crucial, impliquer l'opposition. Parce que si on veut faire perdurer ces réformes au-delà des législatures, sauf à penser que,
un parti ou deux partis se maintiennent au pouvoir ad vitam æternam, voilà, il mieux valu impliquer l'opposition.
Maintenant, un travail a été fait et il est hors de question de le jeter à la poubelle. Je pense que ce serait le pire, mainte-- 'fin, que ce serait encore pire.
Je veux dire, le statu quo, c'est juste impossible. Donc maintenant, des réformes sont mises en place, il va falloir les adapter, hein.
Il y a certainement, 'fin il y a des adaptations qui sont déjà aujourd'hui criantes, hein, même si le rapport date maintenant d'il y a un peu plus de deux ans, ouais, presque trois ans.
L'avis numéro trois, celui qui est la base des réformes en cours, il y manque par exemple la pénurie des enseignants.
On parle pas-- le pacte ne parle pas de la pénurie des enseignants. Or, c'est le problème majeur que vivent les écoles aujourd'hui.
On manque d'enseignants. Donc il y a des adaptations. Il faut faire participer les enseignants, ce qui n'a pas été fait la législature passée.
Et puis tous les aspects sur la bienveillance et le plaisir d'apprendre doivent être beaucoup plus développés.
D'accord. Et donc les points sur lesquels on a le plus communiqué au sujet de ce pacte, ce sont par exemple des choses comme
la suppression du redoublement, le latin obligatoire jusque en troisième secondaire, oui donc le fameux tronc commun.
Ça, ce sont des points que vous ne souhaiteriez pas réformer ? Enfin adapter.
Alors, l'interdiction du redoublement, il n'y en a pas. Le pacte ne prévoit pas d'interdiction du redoublement.
Oui, c'est, on en a beaucoup parlé, mais-
Oui.
Fake news, je ne sais pas.
Le redoublement va être régulé différemment et donc il va devoir être, comment dire, mieux motivé par les enseignants et expliqué aux parents, mais il est pas du tout interdit.
Ceci dit, moi, je trouve que c'est pas une bonne chose, le redoublement. C'est pas une méthode pédagogique qui est-
Efficace
...efficace globalement. J'veux dire, les études l'ont prouvé. Maintenant, je ne pense pas qu'on supprime le redoublement en disant qu'il est interdit.
J'veux dire, c'est pas en fait au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, en adoptant des décrets, que-- c'est pas en faisant comme cela qu'on arrive à des résultats.
Au contraire, il faut donner aux enseignants, à la base, dans chaque classe, les méthodes pour pouvoir ne pas y avoir recours, en fait.
Et donc c'est pas le top down, en fait, qui mettra fin au redoublement. Au contraire, c'est vraiment dans chaque classe et auprès de chaque enseignant qu'on doit trouver les méthodes, donner les outils pour l'éviter.
Ça, je pense, l'histoire des réformes de l'enseignement en Belgique francophone le démontre à foison. C'est pas, euh-
C'est pas au Parlement
...c'est pas au Parlement que,
ce grand-- disons, c'est assez inutile quoi. Si au Parlement, on décide, comme ça a été le cas il y a quelques années, de supprimer le redoublement en première secondaire, qu'est-ce qu'on a vu ? Que
énormément d'enfants doublaient en deux-- à la fin de la deuxième secondaire. Donc, j'veux dire, ce genre de décisions, je pense, 'fin, je pense et j'espère qu'on a compris que c'était pas comme ça qu'il fallait les prendre.
Donc, si demain le CDH n'est pas dans la majorité, mais qu'Écolo s'y trouve, on va garder beaucoup d'aspects, beaucoup de points qui ont été travaillés dans cette réforme.
Le plan du numérique, par exemple.
Oui.
C'est flou à ce stade. On comprend pas très bien,
comment le numérique sera intégré. On parle parfois de cours de programmation, on parle parfois de bring your own device, d'amener les tablettes dans les classes, etc.
'Fin, on peut le-- ça part un peu dans tous les sens.
Ouais.
Quel est votre point de vue, votre approche de la présence du numérique dans les écoles ?
Sur le numérique dans le Pacte d'excellence, il y a un grand plan, etc. Mais je le trouve très décevant.
D'accord.
Je trouve que, en fait, il se passe une chose majeure avec le numérique, qui n'est pas tellement liée aux outils.
Je trouve que le Pacte parle beaucoup des outils. Je dis pas que c'est pas une question importante, mais le numérique va modifier fondamentalement le rapport des êtres humains à la connaissance, au savoir, à l'information, au monde.
Fondamentalement. On va vers un monde complètement neuf. Et je rends hommage d'ailleurs à Michel Serres qui vient de décéder, qui a,
malgré son grand âge, analysé cela de manière, me semble-t-il, très juste et très optimiste.
Ce qu'il dit, c'est que
de la même manière que l'apparition de l'écriture a modifié le rapport des êtres humains aux savoirs ou l'apparition de l'imprimerie, le numérique va aussi profondément modifier notre rapport au monde et notre manière de penser.
On le voit, hein, même si-- 'fin, je veux dire, même,
ma génération qui n'était pas une génération du numérique et qui, voilà, qui a appris le numérique en cours de route, je vois bien que j'utilise mon cerveau différemment d'avant.
J'veux dire, l'exemple des numéros de téléphone, par exemple, je trouve tout à fait parlant. Je me souviens du numéro de téléphone de mes grands-parents, un fixe, mais je ne connais pas le numéro de téléphone de mon compagnon.
Je me souviens quand moi, j'étais à l'école et que mon prof de maths m'expliquait qu'on n'aurait pas de calculatrice dans notre poche pendant toute notre vie.
Oui, c'est-
En fait, si.
Oui, oui. Mais donc, on v-- voilà, on est-- et on voit bien comme on est déjà aujourd'hui totalement perdu quand on n'a pas son téléphone avec soi.
Parce qu'on y stocke une partie des choses qu'on n'y stockait pas avant. C'est-à-dire qu'on stockait dans son cerveau avant.
Ou la manière dont on fixe des rendez-vous, la manière dont on appréhende la géographie ou le, j'veux dire-
Donc, vis-à-vis de l'école, comment est-ce qu'il faut adapter l'école ?
Mais donc moi, je,
je pense que c'est vraiment pas simple. Je pense qu'on est en plein dans cette révolution numérique et que ça va prendre du temps, en fait, de se rendre compte du changement dans lequel on est et de voir-
Ça serait temps quand même.
Oui, oui, mais je veux dire, une modification aussi importante du rapport au savoir,
je pense que ça-- y a pas, déjà aujourd'hui, une formule idéale où on peut dire : "Ah oui, mais si on fait ça, alors c'est bon, les enfants de demain seront dans la..." Voilà.
La solution n'est peut-être pas claire, mais le constat, le fait que le rapport a changé, ça, je pense que-
Ça, je le dis pas dans le Pacte d'excellence, par exemple. Donc ça, je ne dis pas qu'on peut trouver aujourd'hui la solution miracle pour tous
et je ne m'attends pas à ce que le Pacte d'excellence le fasse parce que je pense que c'est compliqué et que ça va prendre du temps,
mais déjà l'amorce de la réflexion, le constat et l'amorce de la réflexion par rapport à ça, ça me déçoit terriblement.
Et je trouve, pour ce que j'ai pu en étudier jusqu'ici, c'est une question qui me passionne, qu'il y a quand même, dans certaines pédagogies, et notamment dans les pédagogies actives, quand même déjà des éléments de réponse.
Et ces éléments de réponse ne passent pas nécessairement par l'utilisation du numérique, en fait. Je vois, j'ai vu des pédagogies, par exemple, avec des jeux de cartes,
où on inculque aux élèves ce qui sera finalement une forme de curiosité ou de,
d'autogestion qui leur sera très utile dans un monde numérique.
Je ne pense pas nécessairement que, voilà, que l'apprentissage du monde numérique ou l'apprentissage de la vie ou de la vie professionnelle dans un monde numérique passe nécessairement par un tableau blanc interactif, quoi. Je,
voilà, je pense que-- mais je pense que voilà, dans certaines pédagogies, il y a déjà aujourd'hui, ou dans certaines,
dans les cours de codage, certainement, mais là, on est vraiment dans du numérique pur, il y a déjà des éléments de réponse qui permettent d'amener les élèves de demain à, ben se débrouiller dans un monde où la connaissance
évolue tout le temps et où l'accès à la connaissance est très aisé, très facile et à portée de clic.
Et donc vous seriez favorable à l'implémentation de cours de programmation, de cours de codage au sein des écoles ?
Oui oui, je serais favorable à-
Oui.
Mais je ne pense pas que ce soit nécessaire pour entrer dans le numérique. Je pense qu'on peut-
Mmh.
Je pense que c'est intéressant, que c'est formateur, c'est un autre langage, comme le latin, en fait.
Oui.
Et donc c'est intéressant de former son esprit à ça. Mais je pense pas que les élèves qui n'auraient pas eu de cours de codage seront perdus dans le monde du numérique.
Ça ne doit pas être la seule approche. Mais oui, effectivement, on avait reçu dans cette émission, il y a un peu plus d'un an,
Nicolas Rolland, qui est donc chercheur en sciences de l'éducation à l'Université libre de Bruxelles,
et qui faisait le constat, effectivement, qu'on avait investi fortement en termes de moyens, en tout cas au sein de la Région bruxelloise, dans les tableaux blancs interactifs, en se disant : « Voilà,
la révolution numérique, elle est faite.
On a mis des tableaux blancs interactifs dans les écoles », en se posant finalement assez peu la question de l'approche, de la pédagogie, et des savoir-faire vis-à-vis du numérique.
Donc, vous faites le même constat. Un autre point dont on parle souvent avec le Pacte d'excellence, et je m'en voudrais de ne pas le mentionner, la proximité entre
le CDH, qui est à la tête de ce Pacte d'excellence, et la firme de consulting McKinsey.
Oui.
Un commentaire à faire là-dessus ?
Oui. C'est une question qui m'a beaucoup fait travailler au début de la législature. Ce qui m'a le plus
le plus interpellée, c'est la manière dont effectivement McKinsey a été choisi pour accompagner le processus,
et qui s'est fait, bon, pour le coup, c'est pas moi qui le dis, mais c'est la Cour des comptes, de manière, je veux dire, le marché public
a grosso modo été taillé sur mesure pour McKinsey et a enfreint un certain nombre de règles relatives au marché public.
C'est, voilà, pour le coup, on a demandé à la Cour des comptes de faire un audit de cela et ça a été clairement, clairement établi par la Cour des comptes.
Donc les conditions dans lesquelles McKinsey est intervenu dans le cadre du Pacte d'excellence sont illégales, en fait. Donc y a pas-
Et ce qui se dit, c'est qu'il y a des proximités entre la tête de McKinsey et Joëlle Milquet.
Oui, donc, voilà. Moi, je- C'est ce qui se, voilà, c'est ce qui peut se dire. Moi, depuis le-- 'fin, voilà, je ne porte pas de jugement par rapport à ça.
Non, c'est sûr, et non.
Mais ce que j'ai constaté et que la Cour des comptes a constaté, c'est cela. C'est que le marché public qui a été lancé a été taillé sur mesure pour ce consultant-là.
Il n'était pas permis à un autre consultant. Alors quand on fait un marché public, normalement, on doit,
on permet à d'autres sociétés de-- 'fin, on lance un appel et tous ceux qui veulent peuvent y répondre.
Il se trouve que les autres concurrents, puisqu'il y en avait d'autres, étaient, 'fin, leur offre était un-- On pouvait pas la comparer à celle de McKinsey puisque McKinsey se faisait,
financer largement, de manière à offrir beaucoup plus de services à la Communauté française pour le même prix, se faisait financer par des fondations extérieures.
Ce qui m'interpelle parce qu'il me semble que quand on parle d'enseignement et de définition des politiques d'enseignement, on est au cœur des politiques de l'État, on parle de l'avenir de nos enfants.
Il me semble que ce sont des politiques qui sont publiques et qui doivent être financées entièrement par le public.
Donc ça, je pense que c'était un énorme problème.
Oui. Et ce qui frappe aussi, c'est que quand on discute avec les, voilà, les agents, les
personnes qui participent à l'écriture de ce pacte, l'implication de McKinsey est toujours un petit peu, 'fin, on sait très bien que c'est le cas, mais
systématiquement, on a l'impression qu'ils le renient, qu'ils font semblant que ce n'est pas le cas.
C'est très, y a quelque chose de très-
Mais donc le-
Secret, très-
Mais oui, mais donc, moi, je trouve, parce que comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure, je pense que, voilà, ça fait partie de la méthodologie de dire qu'ils faisaient des négociations du Pacte d'excellence à huis clos, et-
C'est ça.
Voilà. Moi, ce que j'entends, c'est que McKinsey était là au début, lors de la phase de diagnostic, et puis n'a plus du tout été présent.
Et de ce que j'entends, de ce qui m'est rapporté, ils étaient discrets. C'est ce qu'on me dit. Voilà.
Mais voilà, 'fin, je n'en sais pas plus que ce qui est-
Un point qui est un petit peu curieux quand on compare la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles et la Flandre, c'est que l'enseignement est divisé en deux chez nous.
On a d'une part l'enseignement obligat-- le ministère de l'Enseignement obligatoire et d'autre part le ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur, alors qu'en Flandre, y a un super ministère qui gère tout.
Et ça pose question quand, par exemple, on parle de réforme de l'enseignement,
d'insérer le numérique dans l'enseignement et qu'on a, d'une part,
une ministre de l'Enseignement obligatoire CDH, un ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur PS et un troisième ministre à la Région, à la Région wallonne et Région bruxelloise,
pour la logistique qui, dans le cas de la Région wallonne, était MR.
Est-ce que ça vous semble le bon système de diviser l'enseignement en deux ministères ?
J'ai envie de dire d'abord qu'on a déjà fait pire. Puisque y a eu une époque-
Vous mettez la barre très bas.
Y a eu une époque où l'enseignement était lui-même, y avait l'enseignement primaire et l'enseignement secondaire avec deux ministres différents.
Effectivement.
Je trouve que c'est pas du tout une question facile. Moi, dans les dossiers que je suis, je suis plus les questions relatives à la petite enfance.
Je trouve aussi qu'il y a un gros problème de continuité entre les milieux d'accueil, donc les crèches, et l'école.
Donc idéalement, pour moi, il faudrait plus de continuité entre l'un et l'autre. Et donc ça pourrait se traduire par un même ministre qui serait le ministre de l'Enfance et le ministre de l'Enseignement.
Donc on peut toujours être frustré des découpages parce qu'ils sont illogiques, si on s'intéresse à l'une ou l'autre continuité.
Donc en soi, que les deux ministres soient différents, ça me choque pas nécessairement. Par contre, ce qui est pas acceptable, c'est de ne pas travailler à la transition.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc c'est pas acceptable, comme on l'a vu cette législature-ci, par exemple, que
on travaille au Pacte d'excellence et donc à la réforme des écoles d'un côté, et on travaille à la réforme de la formation initiale des enseignants, donc aux études pour devenir enseignant,
au sein du cabinet et du ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur sans vraiment se parler.
C'est ça.
Et qu'il faille, au moment où on arrive au Parlement, on dit : "Ah tiens, mais en fait, ça correspond pas. La réforme de la formation initiale ne correspond pas."
Ça, c'est inacceptable. Le problème, c'est pas tellement qu'il y ait des ministres différents, mais c'est le manque de continuité dans le même gouvernement.
Oui. Et donc la solution à ce moment-là, c'est de bien faire les choses au moment de la formation du gouvernement et c'est tout ?
Et que les ministres parlent un peu et pas chacun pour soi, et-
Ça, en Belgique, c'est compliqué.
Oui, c'est compliqué. Donc moi, j'espère et je pense qu'on peut faire beaucoup mieux.
Faut dire aussi que, 'fin, je veux dire, l'entente entre le PS et le CDH, ça n'a pas été excellente au cours de cette législature, puisqu'il y a eu-
C'est sûr
...cet événement, voilà, et que ça n'a pas facilité les choses. Pendant des mois et des mois, ils se sont plus parlés, ils se voyaient au Parlement pour s'engueuler.
Donc voilà, ça n'a pas aidé. Donc faut espérer-- 'fin, je trouve que la cohésion au sein d'un gouvernement, le fait de former une équipe, est très importante.
Vous vous étiez faite remarquer il y a quelques mois au moment du vote sur le décret concernant les écoles DASPA.
Mmm-hmm.
Vous aviez alors introduit plusieurs amendements et vous vous étiez abstenue lors du vote final, puisque vous jugiez que certains points vous posaient encore problème.
J'aimerais qu'on revienne là-dessus un instant. C'est un dossier que vous suivez de près. D'après vous, qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire des élèves, entre guillemets, les élèves DASPA, qui sont non alphabétisés ?
Oui.
Puisque actuellement, on sait que ces élèves-là, quand ils arrivent au sein des écoles DASPA, sont trop jeunes pour entrer en formation adulte.
On les met pas dans le spécialisé, on les met dans le circuit traditionnel. Quelle solution ?
Oui. Surtout que les classes DASPA sont des classes donc d'accueil pour primo-arrivants. Donc quand ils arrivent en Belgique, ils sont accueillis dans des classes spécifiques où on va insister sur l'apprentissage du français.
Ça existe dans le primaire, ça existe dans le secondaire. Y a effectivement un énorme-- donc c'est une question qui me préoccupait beaucoup.
Et on a d'ailleurs fait adopter ici, au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, une résolution sur le fait d'avoir une Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles hospitalière.
Et donc c'est important pour nous de pouvoir accueillir tous les enfants.
L'objectif, c'est de les amener le plus vite possible à rejoindre des enfants qui habitent ici depuis plus longtemps et qui maîtrisent le français suffisamment pour être dans l'enseignement ordinaire.
Alors, pour les plus jeunes, ça va, même quand ils-- 'fin, ça va, je veux dire, voilà, c'est pas évident, et c'est sûr que quand ils arrivent,
à 10, 11, 12 ans sans être alphabétisés, y a énormément de travail à faire, mais à ces âges-là, y a encore beaucoup d'espoir par rapport à leur futur.
Dans le secondaire, donc, les non alphabétisés dans le secondaire, dont vous parliez y a un instant, c'est beaucoup plus compliqué.
Et c'est sûr qu'un an de DASPA, puisqu'aujourd'hui, c'est ça qui est prévu, un an de classe dans ces,
dans ces classes d'accueil primo-arrivants, ça peut être un petit peu prolongé, mais enfin, grosso modo, un an, un an et demi, c'est insuffisant pour des élèves qui ont 14, 15 ans, 16 ans,
qui sont en obligation scolaire, donc qui, je veux dire, ils arrivent en Belgique, ils sont soumis à l'obligation scolaire, quelle que soit leur nationalité.
Heureusement. Et après un an, un an et demi, on doit les rediriger quelque part, alors que c'est sûr que c'est pas en un an et demi, à 14, 15 ans, qu'on leur apprend et le français et à lire et à écrire.
Donc là, y a une grosse, grosse difficulté par rapport à ces enfants-là. Ces enfants-là, ces adolescents-là, ils sont grands à cet âge-là.
Moi, je pense qu'effectivement, les mettre dans l'enseignement spécialisé ou dans l'enseignement en troisième professionnel, ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui, c'est, 'fin, ça va pas du tout.
En fait, on attend--
en fait, grosso modo, ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui, c'est attendre qu'ils aient 18 ans pour ne plus qu'ils soient en obligation scolaire et qu'ils puissent alors passer dans des circuits plus classiques d'alphabétisation.
Moi, ça, c'est un peu absurde. Moi, je pense que,
je pense qu'on doit être généreux avec ces enfants-là,
'fin, avec ces jeunes-là, et qu'il faut leur permettre immédiatement de continuer à bénéficier comme ils en ont bénéficié pendant le temps où ils étaient dans les DASPA, de cet accompagnement spécifique.
Et, je veux dire, tant qu'ils n'ont pas 18 ans, ils sont en obligation scolaire. Donc, on espère, 'fin, notre société espère qu'ils vont pouvoir encore apprendre.
Et donc moi, je n'aimerais pas du tout qu'on les mette en troisième professionnel pour attendre qu'ils aient 18 ans et qu'ils quittent l'école.
Donc, je trouve qu'il faut trouver des accompagnements spécifiques pour qu'ils puissent continuer-
Mmm-hmm
...à apprendre à lire et à écrire. Je pense que c'est vraiment indispensable pour
pour tout le monde et ça prend plus qu'un an, un an et demi, et apprendre suffisamment le français pour après essayer de trouver la formation qui leur correspond.
Oui. Donc, à ce stade, le nombre d'élèves non alphabétisés en école DASPA, ça représente un chiffre important ?
Je pourrais pas l'évaluer. Je le sais-
Est-ce que c'est très anecdotique ou bien est-ce que c'est récurrent ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on voit souvent ?
C'est pas... Oui, y en a beaucoup.
Mmm-hmm.
Y en a beaucoup. Et des écoles à Bruxelles qui en connaissent beaucoup et qui en accueillent beaucoup et qui me disent que si elles avaient le double des classes qu'elles ont, ces classes seraient remplies.
Oui, y en a. Donc c'est un nombre significatif.
Mmm.
En tout cas, assez significatif pour qu'on fasse un parcours spécifique pour eux.
D'accord. Et actuellement, ce n'est pas encore le cas ?
Non, non. Donc, y a ce parcours DASPA qui dure un an, un an et demi. Et puis après...
C'est ça. Et c'est quelque chose que vous aimeriez réformer, que vous aimeriez-
Certainement. Oui, oui, c'est sûr. Moi, 'fin, si on s'intéresse aux questions d'enseignement, c'est pour que
C'est pour que chaque enfant, chaque élève, chaque adolescent ait la possibilité de s'ouvrir des horizons.
Et donc ça vaut globalement, mais ça vaut pour chacun d'entre eux.
Un mot à présent sur la laïcité au sein des écoles. En Belgique, en tout cas en Belgique francophone, dans l'écrasante majorité des écoles, donc on parle de 95 % des écoles,
on ne peut pas porter le voile islamique au nom de la laïcité, 'fin, au nom du règlement intérieur de chaque école, qui peut décider à sa guise si elle autorise ou non le port du voile.
Mhm.
Mais une fois passé le seuil de la porte, on a droit à des cours de religion et à des crucifix accrochés au mur. Quelle est la position d'Écolo vis-à-vis de la place du religieux dans les écoles ?
Oui. Donc la position d'Écolo est que la religion a encore sa place aujourd'hui à l'école et donc on n'est pas pour la suppression de ces cours.
Par contre, ce qu'on estimait essentiel, c'était que,
c'était que les enfants puissent, les enfants et les élèves, puissent aborder tous ensemble la question des différents courants religieux et aussi de la philosophie de la citoyenneté.
Et donc on est heureux qu'au cours de cette législature, on ait pu avancer dans cette direction-là avec la création de ce cours d'éducation à la philosophie et la citoyenneté.
Ça, c'est juste pour le réseau officiel, si je ne dis pas de bêtises.
Donc le cours a été-- Il y a une petite spécificité un peu curieuse et aussi typiquement belge, c'est que effectivement, dans le cours...
Le cours est, si vous voulez, les référentiels du cours sont obligatoires pour tous les élèves.
Mhm.
Mais le cours en tant que tel, aujourd'hui, ne doit être organisé que dans l'enseignement officiel, à raison d'une heure par semaine.
L'enseignement libre peut l'enseigner transversalement à travers tous ces-
C'est ça.
Et donc là, nous, on trouve que tous les élèves, parce que, 'fin, que tous les élèves devraient pouvoir bénéficier de ce cours, quel que soit le réseau auquel ils sont affiliés.
D'accord. Donc ça, c'est pour la question du cours de citoyenneté.
Mhm.
J'aimerais revenir sur l'espèce de contradiction que je pointais, cette idée qu'on interdit le port du voile au nom de la laïcité, mais on a un enseignement qui est fondamentalement religieux-
Ouais.
...en tout cas dans la majorité des cas. Est-ce que vous n'y voyez pas une contradiction ?
Oui, donc nous, sur la question du port de signes convictionnels, on estime que, avant-- Oui, il y a une forme de contradiction, c'est sûr.
Mais donc on estime qu'avant un certain âge, il faut protéger les enfants et avoir des règles qui soient similaires pour tout le monde.
Et donc, nous, on estime que jusqu'à un certain âge, on ne doit pas accepter dans les écoles le port de signes convictionnels.
Mais à partir d'un certain âge,
de discernement, de raison, les élèves ont le droit d'avoir des convictions et, dans la liberté d'avoir des convictions, il y a la liberté d'avoir des convictions dans sa tête.
Il y a aussi la liberté de les exprimer. Et les exprimer, c'est aussi dans la manière dont on est habillé.
Et donc, nous estimons qu'à partir d'un certain âge, on devrait permettre, mais ça devrait être une règle
valable dans toutes les écoles, on devrait permettre aux élèves de pouvoir porter des signes convictionnels s'ils le souhaitent.
Ça ne peut pas être une,
un, une excuse ensuite pour ne pas assister à certains cours, par exemple, mais on estime qu'à partir d'un certain âge, les élèves ont le droit d'avoir des convictions et devraient avoir le droit aussi de les exprimer.
C'est là qu'on voit que la définition du mot laïcité varie très très fort entre les différents intervenants. On avait dans ce podcast Nadia Geerts, il y a quelques mois.
Oui.
Voilà. Apparemment, vous la connaissez.
Et donc, donc clairement, le sens du mot laïcité n'est pas le même dans sa bouche et dans la vôtre.
Oui, c'est, oui, c'est évident.
C'est évident. Vous ne voulez pas aller plus loin ?
Moi, je... Non, je ne veux pas, parce que c'est-
Oui, on sent que le sujet de la laïcité est un petit peu un champ de mines pour, pour les politiciens et-
Moi, je trouve que-
...pour Écolo dans cette campagne en particulier.
Non, je trouve que on vit dans une société où les différentes religions peuvent s'exprimer.
Donc j'ai pas de... Je pense que la neutralité de l'État, d'une part, et par ailleurs, la diversité des convictions que peuvent avoir les citoyens, elles s'expriment.
Je pense pas qu'il y ait nécessairement de gros problèmes, en fait.
Mhm.
Et, mais alors, on peut avoir des combats doctrinaux sur la laïcité, la définition de la laïcité, de la neutralité, est-ce qu'il faut l'inscrire dans la Constitution ?
Moi, 'fin, moi, j'ai pas l'impression... J'ai l'impression que des choses se passent et des choses évoluent, mais de manière, 'fin, de manière relativement harmonieuse, en fait, hein.
Mhm.
Donc y a bien sûr des heurts et bien sûr qu'il y a des demandes, qu'il y a des demandes fortes par rapport à certains secteurs.
Mais je trouve que en Belgique, on a quand même l'occasion de se parler, et que des choses évoluent.
J'aimerais rev-, 'fin, puisqu'on parle l'espace d'un instant, et on va passer à autre chose après, mais puisqu'on parle l'espace d'un instant de la question de la laïcité, de la neutralité,
Ecolo Kroon, au conseil communal, déclarait il y a quelques...
Je crois que c'était il y a un an ou deux : « Au nom de ce principe de neutralité que vous utilisez comme instrument de discrimination, de stigmatisation d'une certaine communauté, vous bafouez la dignité de ces femmes.
» Donc, il y a apparemment, dans la définition de la laïcité, de la neutralité chez Écolo, cette idée qu'elle est utilisée comme une arme pour discriminer certaines communautés ?
Je pense que, si je me souviens bien, cet épisode, on parlait là de femmes qui souhaitaient avoir accès à l'enseignement de promotion sociale.
Donc on parlait de femmes adultes, et de, il y a des règlements d'ordre intérieur de promotion sociale qui interdisent le port de signes convictionnels.
Voilà, alors qu'on parle d'enseignement pour des adultes. Là, je pense qu'il y a une énorme contradiction.
On dirait, l'enseignement de promotion sociale, c'est l'enseignement de l'émancipation, de la deuxième chance. On a des personnes adultes qu'on souhaite émanciper, hein, qu'on souhaite qu'elles puissent s'émanciper.
Et parce qu'elles portent le foulard, en fait, on les rejette, pardon, de cet enseignement.
Donc, y a une contradiction énorme qui a donné lieu à la phrase que vous avez donnée et à laquelle je souscris pleinement.
Je veux dire, y a une— 'fin, ça ne va pas de dire à la fois que les femmes qui porteraient le foulard, il faudrait qu'elles s'émancipent, mais en même temps leur fermer la porte des institutions de promotion sociale.
C'est complètement absurde. En plus, là, on parle clairement d'adultes. Donc, 'fin, moi aussi, ça me révolte, en fait, ce genre de décision.
Ouais.
Donc, j'aurais pu tenir les propos qui ont été tenus à l'époque.
Un petit mot également sur cette histoire de tract, en fin de campagne électorale, c'était il y a quelques semaines ici à Bruxelles. Donc,
un tract électoral qui a été distribué au nord-ouest de Bruxelles, là où la communauté musulmane est très représentée, un tract qui reprenait des éléments de langage du style,
l'abattage d'animaux sans étourdissement, le port du foulard, 'fin, des éléments très caractériels de la communauté musulmane, en résumant finalement cet électorat-là aux questions religieuses.
Les réactions au sein d'Écolo, j'ai cru remarquer, étaient assez diverses puisque voilà, je me souviens d'un tweet de Gil Van Den Burg qui condamnait fermement ce tract.
Et puis, finalement, la personne qui était à l'origine de ce tract, Zoé Génault, l'assume finalement pleinement.
Non, elle l'a retiré, hein.
Elle l'a retiré, mais elle-
Moi, je veux dire, les réactions étaient unanimes par rapport à ce tract. Ce n'est ni notre manière de faire de la politique, ni de,
ni par ailleurs, on n'a pas— 'fin, dans ce tract, y avait des simplifications extrêmes de,
de la manière dont on aborde ces questions-là, qui sont des questions complexes, je veux dire, et qui soulèvent des réactions passionnelles importantes.
Et je le comprends. Je veux dire, ce sont des sujets importants et qui touchent les personnes, donc qui méritent d'être abordés avec les nuances nécessaires.
Donc, on n'a pas l'habitude de s'adresser à une communauté en particulier. On a l'intention de faire de la politique pour tout le monde.
On n'a pas non plus l'habitude de s'adresser aux gens de cette manière-là. Donc le tract, dès qu'il a été connu, il a été demandé qu'il soit retiré.
Et les auteurs de ce tract, parce que c'était pas un tract collectif, c'était une initiative de deux candidats, il a été retiré.
Fin de l'histoire ?
Oui, fin de l'histoire, oui, les choses ont été claires par rapport à ce tract-là.
Ce qui frappait également dans le cadre de ce tract, c'est que le bien-être animal est une cause que défend Écolo depuis longtemps.
Et on le voit à présent, en tout cas au sein de ce tract, défendre l'idée qu'il faut défendre l'abattage sans étourdissement.
Et puis finalement, non, finalement, on retire et finalement quand même si. Une position très floue, alors que du côté de chez Groen, leur position est parfaitement claire : on condamne l'abattage sans étourdissement.
C'est pour ça que je dis simplification à l'extrême, parce que ce qui était mis sur ce tract par rapport à cette question-là, ne correspond pas à la réalité.
En Wallonie, il y a eu un,
un décret qui concernait le bien-être animal,
l'ensemble du bien-être animal et pas uniquement la question de sa mort, hein, parce que le bien-être animal, on l'espère, concerne l'ensemble de la vie des animaux et pas uniquement la manière dont on les tue.
Et donc ce décret a été soutenu par les écologistes.
En Wallonie, oui.
Là où il y a peut-être un public musulman moins important.
C'est là que le décret a été déposé sur la table. Et pas-- C'était pas une initiative des écologistes, c'était une initiative des autres.
Donc le décret a été déposé sur la table en Wallonie. À Bruxelles, ce que nous avons dit, mais pas seulement nous, c'est que ce décret,
le décret dont on parle, il est aujourd'hui attaqué à la Cour constitutionnelle.
Il fait l'objet de recours. Donc, on attend simplement de savoir quel est le résultat de ces recours pour voir quelle législation adopter à Bruxelles par rapport à cette question.
C'est simplement là qu'on en est aujourd'hui.
Donc vous rejetez toutes les accusations d'électoralisme, de cette ambiguïté. Le fait que le décret n'a pas encore été passé à Bruxelles, c'est en raison d'une présence importante d'un électorat musulman ?
Là, il y a une prudence de la part d'Écolo et aussi des autres partis, par rapport au fait que la législation qui a été adoptée en Wallonie est effectivement,
est effectivement en recours à la Cour constitutionnelle.
C'est une question de prudence.
Encore un mot sur les élections, puisqu'on parlait de la campagne. Parler à présent du résultat des élections fédérales.
Les électorats diffèrent évidemment selon les partis et on a pu lire de nombreux articles mettant en avant le fait que l'électorat Écolo-Groen était particulièrement diplômé, lettré, alors que, en revanche, celui du Vlaams Belang, qui
lui aussi a fort monté, dimanche dernier, l'est beaucoup moins.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez cette ascension soudaine du Vlaams Belang ?
Je pense qu'il va falloir vraiment beaucoup y réfléchir, parce que c'est terrifiant, mais en même temps, ça vient juste d'arriver.
Donc, je pense qu'il va falloir effectivement,
analyser de manière très approfondie d'où vient cet électorat, quels sont les partis, finalement, qui ont pâti de cette montée du Vlaams Belang,
et quelles sont les causes profondes.
Est-ce que... Et bon alors, moi, j'en vois plusieurs, mais je trouve qu'il faut les analyser.
Bon, il y a certainement la politique menée par le gouvernement fédéral précédent. Je trouve que plusieurs lignes rouges ont été franchies, qui m'avaient choquée comme démocrate, hein.
Je veux dire, quand on parle des migrants en utilisant des termes comme nettoyer, je pense que c'est grave.
Je pense que c'est très grave et ça me choque d'autant plus que, vos auditeurs ne le voient sans doute pas, mais je suis d'origine rwandaise.
Et voilà, je trouve que déshumaniser des personnes, c'est extrêmement grave. Ça me, voilà, c'est quelque chose qui m'interpelle très fort.
Ou, à d'autres situations comme, on se souvient de Theo Francken qui avait refusé de se soumettre à une décision de justice.
Voilà, ça s'est porté atteinte de manière directe à l'État de droit, hein. L'État de droit, ça veut dire que le droit s'applique à tout le monde, y compris, et en particulier aux personnes qui représentent l'État,
et donc en l'occurrence à des ministres ou à d'autres mandataires politiques.
Donc là, y a quand même des lignes rouges qui ont été franchies par le gouvernement fédéral précédent. Et quand,
quand on peut dire cela à la tête de l'État, y a pas de raison de ne pas le penser dans sa tête quand on est un simple citoyen
ou de pousser Vlaams Belang dans l'isoloir ou voter Vlaams Belang dans l'isoloir quand on en a l'occasion.
Donc, je trouve que-
La première raison que vous mettez en avant alors, c'est la politique du dernier gouvernement ?
Après, on parle beaucoup de la campagne qu'a menée le Vlaams Belang sur les réseaux sociaux. On sait qu'il se passe des choses sur les réseaux sociaux et que ça a des influences sur la réalité.
On l'a vu au cours de la législature avec toutes les questions de complotisme, par exemple. On l'a vu avec l'élection de Donald Trump aux États-Unis.
Et là, y a certainement un champ, ben semble-t-il, hein, puisque moi, j'ai pas encore analysé ça de près, le Vlaams Belang a, semble-t-il, fait fort appel à ce type de campagne sur, euh-
Oui, c'est ça donc-
Sur Internet très très ciblée.
On estime plus de sept cent mille euros dépensés en campagne Facebook, sur leur page, sur la page du président, etc.
Et j'imagine ciblée, voilà.
Oui, mais, pour vous donner une idée, même moi, j'en ai vu une sur Instagram et quand je cliquais sur le petit bouton : « Pourquoi est-ce que je vois cette pub ?
» On me disait : « Ben vous êtes un homme, vous vivez à Bruxelles ».
Ah ouais.
Donc quand on utilise des critères aussi faibles que ça, il faut payer cher pour compenser, pour être sûr que le public visé le voit.
Donc, clairement, y a un budget, oui. On le voit, hein, les comptes ont été publiés, plus de sept cent mille euros dépensés.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas vu à ce moment-là un phénomène semblable du côté francophone, une montée d'extrême droite ?
C'est une bonne question. Je veux dire, je m'interroge depuis une semaine là-dessus.
Et pourquoi aussi on l'a pas vu venir ? Parce qu'on n'a pas senti, ni même mes collègues de Groen avec lesquels je parle régulièrement, cette montée en puissance aussi forte du Vlaams Belang.
Qu'est-ce qui nous en prémunit ? Moi, je refuse de dire que ça ne nous arrivera jamais. Ça peut arriver aussi en Belgique francophone.
Et donc je continue de penser que, en matière d'enseignement, certainement, d'éducation aux médias, ce sont des enjeux cruciaux pour demain.
Et en termes d'éducation aux médias, alors, on a de la chance que ça ne soit pas arrivé ici en Belgique francophone, mais y a du travail à faire, hein.
Ouais.
J'ai lu-- parce que cette question numérique m'intéresse beaucoup. La question de l'éducation aux médias, ben suite aux attentats, hein, on y a quand même travaillé.
Ben oui, la question du complotisme, etc. Mais on est nulle part en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles sur l'éducation aux médias, que ce soit vis-à-vis des jeunes ou même des adultes ou des personnes plus âgées, hein.
Je lisais récemment un article qui disait que des personnes âgées relayent plus des fake news sur les réseaux sociaux que des jeunes.
Alors que, voilà, on s'imagine qu'avec des cours de critique historique qu'ils ont pu avoir à l'époque, etc., ils devraient en être prémunis.
Ou leur, comment dire, leur expérience de l'importance des médias, de ce que c'est être un journaliste, etc.
Ils devraient moins relayer des fake news que les jeunes. Ben on constate que c'est pas le cas. Donc en termes d'éducation aux médias,
pour les jeunes, mais aussi pour les adultes, hein, aussi, je veux dire, c'est aussi le rôle du média de service public, hein, de faire de l'éducation aux médias.
Y a un champ énorme.
Donc c'est assez grave puisque on sait que c'est un phénomène qui gangrène, entre guillemets, tout l'Occident et qui touche, voilà, les jeunes, les plus âgés, tout le monde.
Vous nous dites, ici, en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, pas de solution.
Non, non, je le déplore.
Oui.
Je dis, on a-- le gouvernement a adopté, mais à l'époque, c'était encore madame Milquet, un plan de lutte contre le radicalisme, où on parlait de montée en puissance de l'éducation aux médias et on n'a rien vu venir, hein.
L'éducation aux médias en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, c'est un euro par an par enfant, point. Je veux dire, on est nulle part en termes d'éducation aux médias.
Et là-dessus aussi, on parlait tout à l'heure du numérique. Je pense pas nécessairement que l'éducation aux médias passe par l'utilisation des médias numériques, mais,
elle passe aussi par l'utilisation des médias numériques, mais pas uniquement.
Mais on est, voilà, y a un champ de travail pour la législature qui vient qui est énorme.
Très bien. Enfin, très bien, non, très mal. C'est déplorable, effectivement.
Au niveau de la formation du gouvernement, est-ce qu'une solution est possible pour un gouvernement fédéral ou bien est-ce que vous faites partie de ceux et celles qui estiment que
on est partis pour cinq cent quarante et un jours sans gouvernement, éventuellement un retour aux urnes après ?
C'est vraiment très très difficile à dire. Moi, voilà, j'espère qu'on va trouver des solutions, mais c'est très compliqué.
Ouais.
Très compliqué.
Oui, très compliqué, ça, c'est sûr. Ben donc vous n'êtes pas opposée, par exemple, à une formation avec, euh...
Enfin, oui, vous êtes opposée à une formation avec la N-VA, avec le Vlaams Belang ?
Ça, c'est certain, oui.
Oui. Vous maintenez vos exclusives, même si on imaginait un discours beaucoup plus social de la part de la N-VA, un changement de discours, ça...
S'ils deviennent écologistes, y a pas de souci. Mais, enfin, je veux dire, nos programmes sont vraiment très très très éloignés.
C'est sûr.
Je veux dire, il faudrait des pas importants pour aller dans cette direction. Mais pour revenir peut-être sur la question de ce qui s'est passé en Flandre et de ce qui va pouvoir se passer demain,
On ne peut pas-- Et de cette, du fait que voilà, le Vlaams Belang a monté en Flandre et que on n'a pas d'extrême droite en Wallonie ou à Bruxelles, puisque ça vaut aussi en fait pour les Flamands de Bruxelles hein.
Les Flamands de Bruxelles, c'est très différent le résultat des néerlandophones à Bruxelles du résultat des Flamands en Flandre.
Moi, je pense qu'il va falloir travailler beaucoup plus ensemble. Je veux dire c'est pas en continuant-- Il faudrait pas qu'on dise que les francophones n'ont pas d'extrême droite pour parler moins avec les Flamands.
Si on tient à la Belgique et si on pense que c'est intéressant d'avoir encore un pays en commun, il faut travailler plus ensemble.
Donc nous, on travaille régulièrement avec Groen.
La solution du confédéralisme, ce n'est pas la vôtre ?
Ah non, certainement pas, non. Et j'entends régulièrement que, bah, depuis une semaine, qu'on dit : « Bah, on n'ira plus à la mer », par exemple, je trouve que c'est une mauvaise idée.
Je veux dire, si on veut que la Belgique continue, si on trouve que c'est une bonne idée de continuer à travailler Flamands et Francophones ensemble, il faut se parler hein.
Oui, on fait le jeu de l'extrême droite si on arrête de se parler, ça, c'est certain.
Et puisqu'on parle de, voilà, de se parler, de maintenir une Belgique unie, on parlait avec Gil Van Elburg de l'idée de faire une circonscription fédérale et de voter-
Oui.
À Arlon pour les Flamands, à Ostende pour les Wallons.
Je pose la question parce que je n'ai pas réussi à trouver une réponse, mais est-ce que c'est un article de la Constitution qui a été ouvert à la révision ou pas du tout ?
Malheureusement, non.
Non, donc c'est foutu.
Il y a eu très peu d'ouverture d'articles. Non, non. Donc ça, hélas, ce sera pas possible.
Par contre, ce qu'on a fait, là, au cours de cette campagne, c'est ce qu'on a appelé des candidats Erasmus, c'est-à-dire que,
en fait, on peut être candidat à la Chambre sans habiter la circonscription, puisque la Chambre couvre l'ensemble de la Belgique.
Donc, on peut être candidat dans une circonscription où on n'habite pas. Et donc, on a accueilli sur nos listes en Wallonie des candidats Groen et Groen a accueilli en Flandre des candidats Écolo sur ses listes.
Donc, on, voilà, on-
Ce qui fonctionne bien pour Écolo Groen, puisque vous êtes relativement contre la personnalisation des programmes.
Et effectivement, là, ça fonctionne bien dans ce cadre-là. Très bien, mais Barbara Trachte, on arrive au bout des 70 minutes ensemble.
Je vous remercie pour-
C'est moi qui vous remercie.
Le temps qu'on a passé ensemble.
Merci beaucoup.
Et chers auditeurs, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Au revoir. Merci beaucoup d'avoir écouté jusqu'au bout. C'était donc le troisième épisode que je publie en 15 jours, histoire de coller un petit peu à l'actualité.
Je vous avoue que je suis très content de retrouver enfin le rythme habituel.
Pour ne pas manquer les prochains épisodes de Septante Minutes Avec, n'oubliez pas de suivre l'émission sur les réseaux sociaux et de vous abonner au podcast.
J'ai mis tous les liens dans la description. Et d'ailleurs, n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer vos suggestions d'invités ou vos retours, ça m'aide énormément.
On se retrouve dans deux semaines. Salut !